okay
for people joining this live stream we
are talking about game theory
and uh this is a topic that we've been
had
lots of pieces for more from language
for years
but we've been meaning to have a
systematic treatment of it
in the language and i see somewhat
disappointingly that there are notes
that i have
from september 2018 of the last version
of this iteration so we are plus three
years
and uh uh hopefully
uh joseph here is going to um
uh um it's going to
we can leave that out there is going to
um
show us how to um
uh make this work okay
so let me just understand the scope okay
so we've got matrix games
game trees okay
i did some work on those recently in
connection with multi-way systems
bayesian games which i don't know what
they are iterative games i understand
what those are
evolutionary games i have no idea how
we're going to parametrize those
and coalitional games which i don't
understand
so okay so now joseph has
proposals for functions
okay all right
explain okay game can be defined by a
utility tensor
n is the number of players
m is the cardinality of the eighth
player's action set
so stephen i have a few examples
uh actually many examples
uh on a notebook good you want to just
send it to me
or yes well i can send or i can
show okay why don't you show why don't
you show
okay i i show these
share my screen oh okay go for it
yep share screening yes
and here it is
okay so um
let's start with matrix games yeah okay
so in case of matrix games uh
first of all i want to
show some kind of design so
there are pre-implemented games like for
example the
prisoner's dilemma and it would look
like
like okay but that's definitely not
gonna be called gpd it'll be called game
of quotes prisoner's dilemma
yes yes yes okay so here everything is
initial
and temporary okay all right okay okay
so um
so this is hold on hold on hold on hold
on hold on
so you know it might be better if i'm
running this notebook i mean so
you've got two game matrices here
for the two i mean two for the two
players correct
yes okay all right so let's just
understand what's happening here
so now okay so then
what we have talked about previously and
you apparently
don't agree with this design is
when there are named actions to use
an association with named keys
rather than a pure matrix
what's the reason not to do that in
other words why why not instead of
having separate action labels and player
labels
why not have this thing uh this in first
argument be an association of
associations
okay so i imagine this as a as a hidden
object so uh in uh in some
stage uh this this game object would be
something which is
hidden from the user and then you can
ask for four
different um representations if you want
so um you could ask for
by by matrix representation
if you want you can ask for an
association representation
that wouldn't be something all right
okay reasonable enough
okay so fine so it doesn't matter so
much but but people are going to have to
you know when they're constructing a
game they have to type something in
and it might be convenient for them to
type in matrices that might be a more
convenient thing for them to construct
um okay i imagine there could be several
constructing
methods uh of of games so you can
construct it from
this association list or you can have
you can construct it from strategic form
from a graph form
etc etc okay okay all right okay fine
all right so this is game object and
um you have a function here payoff
matrix but that could as well be a
property
of that game object yes it could be
okay and and if is that just to display
a thing that we're seeing there or is
that yes
yes it is it's playing in a
in an understandable way and this
this decoration by labels uh is is
optional
so uh the main thing from point of view
of uh
calculating equilibria etc the main
object obviously right payoff right
metrics or payoff tensor
okay okay
i mean this this this output could be
more beautiful i mean it could be more
graphically
presented it seems to me but this is
certainly i mean
yeah i mean that's the detail but given
that this thing is going to be a
property
of this game object which i think should
be called a game object not a game but
anyway
um the the um
uh okay so it's just a property that is
a display form
i get it okay all right okay then here
are some
several other examples like the rock
paper scissor
uh there is this uh so so let me ask you
this so
so the way we would normally do this
like for example net model
for neural networks has a repository
right so
in other words if you have a name first
argument with a string
you know game object of quote rock paper
scissors
right the way the clean way to set that
up would be
to have a repository of games yes that
like the repository of neural nets where
we just have a big collection of these
things how many of these things are
there that are named
is other you know 10 other 50
how many are named well um
uh in on wikipedia for example there is
listed
let's say 10 uh well-known uh games
without parameters
and there are several 30 with with
parameters which are
and player games okay all right fine
okay okay so that's a i mean initially
it could be done just to something where
it's documented
in the you know there's a list of what
the possible games are documented in the
game object documentation
and then subsequently it could become an
actual
um uh repository okay i get it
all right three player game okay here i
wanted to show a
three-player green game that how the
structure would
uh look like so here we don't have only
two mattresses but it's
it's a tensor actually sure and you
have to represent it in a nested nested
form yep
just like table form matrix form
whatever do but this is fine this is
nice
i mean i think given that this would be
some
you know this graphic design that should
be done to make this more beautiful but
this is basically
structurally makes sense okay
um and then uh here i just uh
implemented a function where you can
generate random games
uh where you can list uh the the
cardinality of action
sets of of a why isn't that just random
real
of uh why isn't that
the equivalent of random real you know
one comma
two two two two uh this
is basically that uh i just simplified
not to
include uh all uh all the time these
tables etc etc so it
it it's it's quite easy it's just why
isn't it just game object of random reel
of one
um maybe it is
okay fine i i it just i mean it seems
like a specialized thing to want a
random game like that i mean i i know
it's an interesting thing to study but
i don't doesn't seem like it needs its
own functions yes here here i included
an extra
thing that you can specify the the
distribution et cetera et cetera
okay that's again something you should
be able to do in the
unless there's a special kind of
distribution for random games
that's different what what is the
distribution of
of those um uh uh
payoff numbers for a random game is it
not uniform distribution
here the default is uniform between zero
and one
and you can specify something like
that right but the correct way to do
that is just to say random real
of normal distribution blah blah blah
comma two two two
two yes so for example
right but i don't think this is the
right way to do it right
right so all you have to do is say if
you just type in
random random real i mean you can just
do the
random reel a pass on distribution of
ten
same thing plus one distribution of ten
yes comma list222 let's say
i think this will just work well
whatever oh
oh integers okay oh oh integers so you
have to say random integer there
random variable works for everything
okay
random variant sounds good okay so that
should give you
if you do two two two four twos that
should that should give you the same
structure
uh i think it doesn't have the right
number of variables in it but
it doesn't have the oh maybe it does to
the sixteen oh you need it
i know what you need you need you need
one more thing you need the number of
players
the first element needs to be the first
or the last element i don't know
last element maybe go
[Music]
it's ahead the right way around anyway
it's something like this
beautiful well that's not quite right
but okay it's something like that
all right keep going this is very nice
okay
uh then another another topic is the
game trees
um and here is uh already something
which is
existing in in war from language so uh i
i get this
uh mad game decision tree uh from the
knowledge
i didn't even know we had that okay
that's the thing that i
i i was looking for a thing like that
okay i
reprogrammed that okay all right
so then uh then i uh just again
uh i use the data structure here which i
imagine should be uh uh
well so so we have a tree data structure
is that what we want to
so i mean that's coming in twelve three
so this will be using the tree
so then you would be saying i would
imagine you'd say
game object of that tree data structure
yes so this
that would be against some kind of
hidden object
uh i just show you what is the internal
data structure here what i use
here we have two kind of
uh two kind of nodes uh there are
decision nodes
which has first of all label then
there is a player which which player
can choose there an action there is an
action
association in an association
meaning that if player 1 says a1 then it
goes to node 2
if it says a2 then it goes to node
3. and here is an empty list
which says that there is no payoff in
this stage
okay so hold on hold on hold on this
should be using
the um uh um
this should be using the existing i mean
the tree functionality that we're
building do you know how that works
uh no okay so you've reinvented some
pieces of it
okay so you should be able to just use
trees
the tree object ian ford isn't here is
he
the no he's not but we can connect
joseph to him yeah please this should be
straightforward
you do not need to reinvent the tree
data structure of course of course
okay this is this is something hidden
and
initial so i just i just okay okay fine
but the basic point here is that
you have a series of layers there's
player one layer player two layer
at each layer you're representing what
happens um according to this game tree
but now where do the payoffs go here
and those are the leaves uh where there
is no possible action but there is a
payoff uh for okay okay for every quick
quick question uh sorry it's jason um uh
for games where the choice order doesn't
matter this is gonna work fine otherwise
is there any notion of the orders in
which players make their choice
giving you different trees uh so
i i would use information sets for that
meaning that in some cases
the player don't know in which stage he
is
precisely only in which
uh subset and uh this is how
uh one can model uh uh
one shot games or matrix games uh in
this way
this is called the imperfect information
oh but okay but wait a minute is this no
longer a tree
so uh an imperfect information game
is a three plus uh subsets
of of nodes
so the the information set
gives an extra hyper graph structure to
the tree graph
well i mean my question is how that's
going to work with the tree data
structure
what you have to have okay so i i don't
quite understand that but that's
something
um okay why don't you try one more time
and you know
if this is a long notebook it really
would be better to send it to me and for
me to drive here
um i thought we were going to go back to
you
you have it in your email okay
um okay so uh
can i go on with this imperfect
information
structure hold on let me let me just um
um
you know it will work much better if i
drive i think
so in that way it's um uh
this works in just the existing version
of our
right it works in existing versions yes
okay first why don't you unshare and let
me share and then we could
go that way first you need to run the
definitions and then okay
okay no problem let's do that um
okay beautiful all right
okay now let me try to understand this
so
and by the way it would be good if we
can get ian here that would be great
okay um
okay so
this is a tree each layer in the tree
represents okay so what what's happening
here i don't quite understand what is
this doing
so you got player one making it a first
choice uh then if player two making a
different choice on either of the trees
uh he's on sub trees based upon what
player one's choice was
right and at the leaves of the of leaves
afterwards he gets to an actual payoff
yeah but why is that so i don't
understand i mean you're going to
you're going to go down this branch or
the other branch
anyway what's the thing what's the
difference
so the payoff the the payoffs uh in the
end
depend on what i mean so here just
mutual choices so
player one chooses to go to the left
side of the right side of the tree and
then
depend on either of those sub trees
player two decides to go to the right or
left branch of the sub tree under him
and the payoffs happen at the end right
this is why yeah
this is why i was saying that the the
issue with this tree representation of
them is that this is
uh visually presenting player two is
making his choice after player one
right but uh it actually is because of
the symmetry of it it's actually
indifferent to the order of the
of the choice at least in a perfect
information case if they're doing
simultaneous choices okay so then what
does the
line mean so if you have them
do the choice in different in in
in a different order but with different
information
um there's a question of do i make the
choice and tell you and then you make
your choice
that's a sequential game with perfect
information yeah right
but if i if i make my choice and and uh
don't tell you
it's the same as if we made it
simultaneously right okay so
games games of uh simultaneous choice
can be modeled as games of
um sequential choice with perfect with
imperfect information
okay but how do they how do you specify
the imperfect information yeah
so here basically the thing is that
player
2 in the first situation knows exactly
what was the choice of player 1
and in the second stage
the second option player 2 doesn't
know in which node he is precisely he
only knows an equivalence class
and that equivalence class is
donated by this by this dotted line i
get it i get it
okay so in general in general as you say
this is a hypograph
yes not a tree yes
cluck cluck i mean in
so it's not completely obvious that you
should use our
i mean having made my case for using the
tree representation
it's not completely obvious that that's
correct
if you want to cover this case as well
yes if you want to
include imperfect information which is a
big class of games then
yes but okay so there's two choices
either you have a wrapper on top of the
tree representation
or um uh
or it's a completely different data
structure um
okay let's keep going just to get a
scope here and then we're going to go
back to more details
um
okay so here you can see a more
complicated
uh game within in perfecting for
information
so this is basically the strategic form
of a bayesian game which will be seen
in a later stage here there are
three players one is special called
nature
or god or random or something
which chooses some types and then
um the players don't know
so the players know only their own type
and then and based on that information
they need to make decisions
but by not jumping further
this is just a representation of an
imperfect information game
which is a little more complicated than
the first one okay
here you can see a hyper graph structure
that the
information sets for player two are
actually
four node uh subsets i get it
so so i mean we have for the physics
project we have a bunch of hypergraph
functionality and visualization yes
that's what you will see
if you go a little okay all right fine
okay uh here i
i wanted to show that uh uh even
uh so here for example in a bayesian
game
nature can so we need to specify
uh the probabilities uh how the nature
works
and maybe by specifying the thickness of
the of the
arrows you can nicely visualize
uh probabilities as well okay on these
decision trees
okay that's different kind of hyper
graph so that's a that's an un
that's a subset based type of graph so
there's no ordering in these
in these sets is that correct yes okay
yes and here i just wanted to show that
there are two standards in literature
how these information sets are
represented
one is these dotted lines and the other
one is these blobs
okay and i just want to i was i had no
time to implement these but there is a
possibility to use blobs as well
so i mean roughly what this will be is
i see given i mean there's two different
things here that we can do
one is the visualization
where this is fundamentally a graph with
you know graph layout and all that kind
of stuff but with additional edges
and then and that's one thing you should
be able to get out
of this game object presumably is
something i mean you could take any game
even you know something specified with
matrices
and you could represent it in this form
right
well uh you can represent any matrix
game with an incomplete information
game it's a little
harder it's it's not obvious if
something can be represented by a
non-complete information by by a perfect
complete information
right that depends that's a condition on
the matrices presumably
yes i i think those are pretty expensive
algorithms
uh to reverse uh the the matrix game to
a strategic
form but it's possible okay but so so
roughly design wise if we have a game
object
and there is an access or a property for
the game object
that corresponds to this graph-like
representation
then by default it will just be the um
uh you know the thing assuming
incomplete information with dotted lines
and so on
um and there's a completely separate
issue of trying to reduce that game to
one that is a complete information
version of the of the game tree version
is that the right way to think about it
um
[Music]
i'm not sure uh so so i mean i i would
think that this would be what would
happen you would have game object
of i don't know what this what was this
one what is this named game
i'm already losing okay uh
matching pennies yes
okay so then it would say something like
this
and it would just say that the simplest
case would be just something
like um you know whatever it is decision
tree
yes and that would return um
and that would return a graph object
and then you could put options onto that
graph object or a decorated graph object
i think well any graph object is a
decorated graph object okay okay
okay it's either a graph object or it's
a tree but probably a graph object
from what you're showing me here
okay
where is this
um okay terrific
okay and then i think one one more um
useful thing would be to actually
combine
different games so so if you have two
uh three representations of games for
example
then you could say that one node one
leaf node is not
anymore a leaf node but start for for
another
game so i think that's how you could
combine these
these games and that's how you you could
construct um
you know more elaborate games from
simple ones
so that will presumably have to be its
own function for games
right because it's going to take game
objects and it's going to take i'm not
quite sure how you
i mean it's similar to a graph union
as a graph what is it similar to for a
tree actually that's an interesting
operation for trees that i'm not sure
we've
thought about that clearly is
you know what happens when you want to
graft a tree on
by putting a tree on the leaves of a
tree yes
um okay
this is great all right game trees into
matrix
games yes okay fine
so here uh there is a
there is a transformation decoration
could be added
but basically what i wanted to show that
these kind of
three forms can be can be transformed to
matrix forms
but but i mean look the way this is
going to work presumably is
you type in game object and you either
give a tensor here
that's one case in which case here you
could say
decision you know decision tree or
decision graph or whatever you want to
call it
and then that returns a graph and that's
the your way of doing the trans
transformation or you put in here
game object of
whatever the tree representation is and
then here you can say
whatever your thing there is payoff
matrix if you just want the display
or if you want the actual matrix well
that will presumably give you the matrix
and then payoff
uh i mean i don't know what the name for
it is
um payoff matrix
i'm just making up this thing because i
don't think this is quite right but
something like this
which would be the graphical version
like this
thing is that different game trees can
give the same matrix structure
for example uh for these matching
pennies you could you can permutate the
players
uh if if player one has
completely information yeah i get it so
what
i i just say that maybe keeping this
this
game tree and game matrix uh um
object is is can be something
justifiable
because uh also if you have a big tree
then
the cost of a new object is extremely
high
the cost of every new object is
supporting it in
n functions right
so it's it's it's usually a bad idea to
have
you know multiple but but
let's keep going let's keep going the
thing is that if you have a bigger tree
then the the possible um
uh actions of different players have a
combinatorical explosion i understand
i understand so but you just explained
that this game object is a is an
opaque object right so it gets to
represent itself internally however it
wants
yes right so all you're doing is you're
saying i want the decision tree for that
fine you get a graph i want the payoff
matrix okay fine you'll get a tensor
and if you know if you've got 10
players and your tensor is a huge you
know
2 to the 10 whatever it is size
no 10 to the whatever it is size thing
then so be it
right i mean if you ask for the matrix
you're going to you've got to be given
the matrix which is might be huge
the thing is that if you represent the
game in tree form
um then maybe
it's impossible to to calculate the
exact nash equilibrium for everything
but maybe you can use
an approximate approximative method
where you don't need to transform that
into a matrix i get it i get it i get it
but
the only reason we're talking about
transforming to a matrix is if the user
asks for it
okay okay i mean i don't think i think
you know with your argument that game
object should be an opaque thing
which you know is a is maybe just fine
then you know
and and um so i think it's something
like
matrices and air rays and sparse arrays
so yes but those are very expensive
those took sparse arrays took probably
five years to implement
well okay right that's why we don't want
to do that
if we don't need to you know it's some
uh uh okay let's keep going
this is very nice by the way i just want
to say that this is
this is a great deal of progress already
and and we've only got to the first part
of the agenda
um really great progress okay let's look
at game solve
okay so in game solve
i just wanted to show how the input and
how the output would look like
so here for example you have the the
payoff metrics of
the prisoner's dilemma and game solves
gives you
a pair of strategies here for example
this 0 1 0 1 meaning that
both players should defect in
in the nash equilibrium and then
i just uh i just visualized uh
how in with this stream plot
uh if one player can
tune its own strategy and the other
player can
tune the other strategy then
how how would these strategies flow
in this space so this is not exactly
replicate their dynamics but something
similar to that
okay hold on hold on so first thing is
this initial game solve
um the uh
um you know for example
one solution is the nash equilibrium so
that's
potentially a second argument to game
solve that we discussed a couple of
years ago
um i think that the the default
um or or
should be the nash equilibrium i think
that's the most
frequent question and then you could
ask different questions or refine
equilibriums
fine but so this thing here of evaluate
strategy
yes this that list is somehow a
representation of the strategy
yes and um
so it gives two to two separate things
first of all it can give up give a
several nash equilibria so from this you
can learn that there is only one
unique nash equilibrium in this
situation where is the definition of
that crazy g
whatever the heck it is or is that is
that is that already defined
if i run this is it going to work
oh yes it did work yeah okay fine i
don't know why it's still blue but
that's okay fine
okay okay
uh yes so from this output you know that
there is only one unique nash
equilibrium
and then it gives you the
the strategies
the mixed strategies of both players
okay okay so in general though
i mean there are more complicated things
that happen with some games where you
don't have point
solutions and so on yes you will see
those
okay all right fine okay okay so here is
for example a coordination game
uh where more interesting things happens
here you have three separate nash
equilibria
one is that both players goes to
bach then to stravinsky and there is the
mixed
there is a minced nash equilibrium as
well
okay okay here again you can see
some kind of uh stream plot or or or
something similar to replicator dynamics
where you can see that there are two uh
stable points
0 0 and 1 1 and there is one saddle
point
which is still a nash equilibrium but
not
uh well if you have two populations then
this is not um
evolutionary stable point
nice okay very nice all right i mean
i i don't yeah okay fine yep
okay then uh here we have uh another one
this is pretty similar to the
coordination game
but with some twists so this is a whole
dove
play and here again you have three
separateness equilibria
two pure and one mixed
okay okay and then
i wanted to show what's happening if you
you have a
multiplayer game so here you have three
players
and they can go to three different
composers uh stravinsky and forzak
and here for example you get seven
separate
nash equilibria
i mean so each one i mean the difference
here between
our because we don't have named
because these are not associations we
don't have named
uh players we're just representing
which player is which position are they
so
yes i mean in in the case where in this
initial case
we just have one um yeah okay so you've
nested the lists correctly here
yes okay good good
yes so these here decoration can be used
uh different output forms can be used
but the basic information what would be
output to this
okay i get it it makes sense right and
this thing in general
is a tensor which is
yeah number of solutions and then within
each solution it's just a list of
of n tuples for each of the
it's the mixed strategy that each player
has so you know two thirds of the time
he says this choice one third of the
time he says that choice
yes
right okay okay
okay uh here i wanted to show that here
is a
a modified version of this where the
third player likes very much uh he's his
favorite
uh composer and i just wanted to show
that uh
this can output symbolical uh solutions
you know it's always a better idea to
have the input and the output paired
with each other otherwise you have to go
back and see what you know
i can see that this is paired with that
but if you just had that as the input
line it would be easier to understand
but okay yeah
all good this is very impressive it's
very cool
and presumably if i had a symbolic
variable in here it would still work
well um not with this initial
implementation but uh there is no obstac
well um you know there are um
i think that would be it's complicated
because there's a question of generosity
of values
yes so so there are a lot of
um if uh
uh and so you know if you tune the
parameter it can change the number of
equilibria
of course right so so we've had to
address that issue
in reduce for example as opposed to
solve
and i mean that's what reduce has full
sort of conditional expressions and so
on to represent
things like that to represent solution
sets which
can have where the structure can change
and so on and i think you know that that
may be
that's a that's a future enhancement but
yes that seems like it would be a good
a very uh you know to have that full
thing as you would get from reduced
rather than from solve
seems like a good idea because that's
what you have to have you're not going
to have any choice about it
it's going to in general you're going to
have all kinds of merging branching
whatever as a function of parameters
right
uh yes yes
okay okay here you have something
similar
so if you want to so it's another game
it's a rebellion game if everybody wants
to
make a rebellion that rebellion happens
and everybody is happy
otherwise uh if the rebellion failed
then
those who tried it gets a kind of
punishment and who
don't try they they are just okay uh
here again i i wanted to say show that
uh here you can
calculate it symbolically as well so pi
and yeah if you are very hacky then you
can
change pi to a variable but that's
it's not very safe and here is just a
visualization how that would look like
because here every three
players has two
[Music]
moves to oh look at that conditional
expressions
yes but uh well i tried that and
it's not going to work i'm going to tell
you right now it's not going to work
because the structure is as you as
you've observed the structure is going
to change
in general and so you're not going to be
able to do something where you have a
fixed collection of lists you will have
to do something like what reduce does
yes it's it's um so it gives something
but
it's not correct no i understand so it's
not going to work
so you shouldn't so potentially what
what you should do
is if you have game solve have a second
argument which says what kind of thing
it's generating
one of the things it generates could be
some kind of uh
you know symbolic representation which
will be just
which will be like what reduce producers
and which will not resolve into explicit
lists
um until you you know give values to the
variables and so on
but where you can manipulate the thing
as a symbolic object and it'll be very
nice and it's essentially a generator
of complicated you know expressions
okay uh then here is just another
rebellion game it's not very
fun interesting uh here i wanted to show
what's happening in a matching pennies
because it has a nice stream plot
uh here it gives you a one half one half
mix
strategy and uh it can happen
so these are magnificent pictures i mean
this is very
helpful in understanding what's going on
in these games yes
go on yeah okay so so that's it
uh well actually let me just understand
from my my moment of actually
understanding what's happening here
so in a picture like this
we're saying p and q are probabilities
yes and when we follow this stream plot
around
what what are we thinking that the
successive
you know arrows correspond to yes
so uh the first player can manipulate
the p
and the second player can manipulate the
queue
and the first player is interested in
maximizing the first payoff
metrics and the second player is
interested in maximizing the second
payoff metrics
and they change their parameter
in a way where they can increase
their payoff i understand but so this is
then the other impression the other the
other player then adapts by changing
theirs and the result is that they
circle
okay so this is an iterative i mean that
one is imagining that the game is
being played iteratively no this is not
internet well and this is not your
iterative and
each person has a choice of pairs out of
this it's not
explicit iteration where you can train
the other player or they react to past
it's it's just that uh if you pick this
parameter they should pick that
parameter and the
the incentives of what what you should
do given what they do
are right so this is in a sense it is
it is iteration but where instead of
having
a you know some realistic algorithm for
what each player is doing
it is at every step the player is
optimally picking
what they should do is that correct you
can you can imagine this as a very
gradual
uh iteration so you don't always
choose the the optimal um uh
the best response for for the other
strategy
you just always make little incremental
changes in your own strategy
yeah so this this is what the stream
plot is actually showing is what would
happen
if you were ignoring the other player's
reaction and just making
infinite decimal changes to your
existing mixed strategy
right um and then they and then they do
the same thing
um you would you would be walking along
each of these curves
oh i see so this is basically just
representing i see
it's it's representing given this result
i should change mine if we're in the
lower part of the diagram right and i'm
i'm playing the player controlling p
i should keep reducing my my the value
of p right
i should make my choices more likely to
be zero and less likely to be one
and as i do that the other player is
going to see that they can improve
things by increasing
the probability that they pick one as
opposed to zero right increasing
sort of yeah right this is just kind of
inside
the calculation of something like a nash
equilibrium this is the
this is the you know were we to
calculate that iteratively as a matter
of numerical analysis
this is what we would see in the
calculation yes
okay well it's a naive approach for that
and
obviously obviously but that's the the
right
okay okay and here
i just wanted to show again another game
this is uh
called rock paper scissors fire water
it has a non uh trivial equilibrium
and you know it just gives that the
equilibrium
that uh whatever that it has it has one
nash equilibrium
the mixed one uh where you should
uh choose uh rock paper scissors with
property one ninth
and then fire water with probability
once okay
i get it i can read that but i mean so
so getting out that graph
which is the you know what's on top of
what
type thing how does that graph
you know in terms of you know your
matrix decision tree etc
that graph is yet a different
representation of what's going on in the
game
no it is it is not um or organically
uh fits into into this and it's it's not
general generalizable i just wanted to
recreate the same plot what is just a
copy of an image i understand but this
is this is somehow
why is it not the case that in a game
you know this is saying water wins over
fire yes
right and so that's saying in terms of
payoffs
that would be saying i mean you could
pick the payoff arbitrarily but it has
to be the case
presumably that that the i mean when you
represent this as a matrix
this payoff is larger than that payoff
is that right
is that how you're representing what's
going on here
yes i mean i mean i mean in this
so this is a two-player zero-sum game
and uh um
i i i would need to think about that how
this generalize is
to to other people i would have thought
that there's a way of drawing it
that is not actually that dissimilar
it's a discrete version of what you're
drawing above
with your um you know stream plots and
so on because this is basically saying
in if if i'm not mistaken the stream
plot
but it's not quite the same thing but
there's there should be a way of taking
some collection of numbers taking both
an adjacency matrix and
creating some collection of numbers
consistent with that adjacency matrix
because these are arbitrary i mean i
could have picked
twos and threes and whatever else
couldn't i here
if the ratios of the payoffs differ from
one cell to another it would actually
change what the nash equilibrium is
um but uh uh if if if you just change
all the minus twos to all the minus ones
to minus
fives and all the plus ones to plus
fives would make any difference so
right any any any scalar multiplication
this is gonna make a difference but if
they're if
you change uh the payoff of water
beating fire sp
i get it yeah right it's gonna change
the ash equilibrium but but this plot
does not define this matrix precisely
all this plot is saying is that water
dominates fire
right it's saying correct that's a
bigger play-off than that so this is
so this is a specific matrix that is a
represent you know
is a particular somehow you know simple
i don't know what
you know it's just a particular
representation there right but i mean
you can you can make a plot like this
for anything
where all of the payoffs are are zero
one or minus one
right um okay yes i'm not sure
i mean i think you need to have a zero
sum game
okay correct correct okay let's keep
going here
okay so here we have replicator dynamics
uh which is uh something which is which
is used in evolutionary game theory
uh the main point is that you can
imagine that
there are replicators which are
using given strategies in
time in the beginning of the in the
of the evolution there is a fixed number
of these of these replicators and then
based on the on the average payoff
for each replicators they can
grow in numbers or shrink in numbers
and um the the fitness
of a replicator is defined by
the game and uh the the population
uh and uh and based on the fitness
there is a there is an increase or a
decrease in numbers
okay and uh and here
there is this replicator dynamics which
basically
uh first of all generates uh the
standard differential
the standard um set of differential
equations
and then it uses nd solve
to solve the differential equation for a
given time period
right so presumably i mean in the actual
structure of this
there should be a way taking the game
object and
for a given game object there is a set
of differential equations which are the
replicated dynamics for that game object
is that true yes
yes this is this is done
internally in this uh in this replicator
dynamics function
and this is with the single population
so uh you know
each is playing against the others with
the probability of the weight of that
its representation in the population
right so there are the other things
which will
yes so there are different options it
can be
a two population replicator dynamics
meaning that
for the role of one player for the role
of the first player
there is one separate population and for
the role of the second player
is a different replicate or different
population
or you can uh actually join those two
uh populations uh in which case
you make you make the er so then they
are playing
uh against each other so
for example in this prisoner's dilemma
case
uh in the in the fixed points uh
it doesn't make any difference so if you
if if the populations are disjoined for
player 1 and player 2 both
in both ways in both populations
cooperation will go down and
defectiveness
goes up uh
here so this is
the grouping the grouping of the
populations
is um is given in the final
part of this replicator dynamics so this
this list in list one
list one list two this says that there
is two populations
in the second in the second case in this
single population replicator dynamics
uh there is one group one two
meaning that uh the the two strategies
are uh selected from the same population
okay we are going to run out of time so
we should we let's
let's zoom forward a bit just to get a
sense of what's here
um okay so here are some other examples
uh here for example in this doha game it
matters actually that if it's a two
population
or a single population okay
okay okay so there's these are lovely
results
but let's for the sake of time that's um
these are quite lovely
quite lovely okay i need to understand
this thing about multi-population
uh thing but we're not going to
understand that right yet
okay let's just i just want to zoom
ahead just to see what we've got here
okay um
okay approximative solutions for this
there are a few uh standard things like
fixtures game
and and the regret matching uh
if you scroll a little down you can see
what kind of sequences
it can produce
so this gives basically a numerical
approximation
uh for it this is this is what this is
doing is it has some internal model
and it is learning i don't quite
understand what learn strategy means
the idea is you have some algorithm for
updating what your strategy should be
based on the feedback of playing the
game that doesn't know about the game
itself
right um but is just trying to
approximate to learn
in all games and then the question is
how well can it learn to play
uh this game in terms of what strategy
does it converge on with that iterative
method
well actually in in fictitious play
you know your own payoff metrics so you
always try to find the best response for
your opponents
okay but from a design point of view if
i were to just feed in my own
arbitrary function to do this kind of
learning
what would be the input to that function
some time series of what has happened
previously in these games or i mean how
does this relate
to for example in general would have to
be would have
in general be have to be a map between
your associated um
choices and payoffs as a pass vector so
you have with some other input
information like knowing your own design
matrix
sorry your own payoff matrix um and then
from that you would have
just a general function from one to the
other is a is a learning
algorithm right so my question is how
does this relate to what we do for gans
generative adversarial networks in
machine learning which i think have the
same issue
actually um uh no i mean
maybe it's more reinforcement learning
that is you do something in the world
right so we have we have functions like
um let's see we have implementation of
this is very very
uh so it's much more basic i don't use
any
i understand i understand that
completely right you do not use machine
learning for this at this time
right although you although my point is
a function like active classification
right
basically you could imagine what in in a
in the right design for this you could
imagine essentially plugging in
one of these machine learning functions
for your
you know strategy learner you see what
i'm saying so what this is doing is
right it's got configurations it's got
sampling functions it's got
payoff functions etc etc etc right so
it will be worthwhile to
you know look at the design of this
which i don't think is that fantastic
but um as a way to understand what
if you were to give an arbitrary
function to be the learning function
what would that look like because i
think that
the um you know the ultimate
right it should be the case that you
could just plug in something from
machine learning
here and have that work do you agree
yes the thing is that there are some
theorems for example about fixtures play
that uh
there are some theorems that if the game
structure is this undead then for
example
the the convergence of the fictitious
play is guaranteed
and things like that i think that's why
some
would i i understand but but you're not
understanding my point
of course there are particular choices
right of what the effective learning
function is
right there are named choices like your
fictitious case
play case right but what i'm asking is
if you the user want to invent your own
new way of doing learning right what how
do you do that
you should be able to just give here in
this learn strategy thing i'm not sure
this argument structure is quite right
something where you just say here's the
function
that will be the the function that is
being fed data about what's going on
in the game and then that function is
going to return things that
is that function is then going to have a
representation of the learned strategy
it is very similar to a behavioral
strategy where basically based on the
game history uh you you give a
you give a move or give a choice but
you can also give give a strategy okay
fine
but so what i'm saying is the design
since well that's what we're talking
about here the design
should map into whatever design we're
using for machine learning
because it should be the case that in a
nice
cool you know generator of many projects
for people
you should be able to use machine
learning to learn game strategies
yes okay i agree i think those can be
harmonized
yes okay fine i mean i i as i say i
don't think this is a fantastic design
for active classification but you need
to you know that would be a good thing
to start off looking at
um that's very nice
okay let's take a look here
okay here the main point is that uh an n
player
uh not an n player non-cooperative game
can be can be transformed to a
cooperative game or a coalitional game
but basically uh the the main point is
that some players can join together
form groups they can they can harmonize
their strategy yeah
and there they can share the pales right
okay so we need a way of representing
that which
yes and here is this uh coalitional game
uh thing which basically which is
represented by a
uh by a set function
uh which gives real numbers for
for subsets and the set of players
and the question what is uh what is
answered here is
that what is the what is the total
payoff uh
what a coalition can get
uh from in a given situation are these
shapley values the same ones as the ones
that are used for credit assignment
in um uh in machine learning
yes i think yes okay
okay okay
and here there are visualization
possibilities there is already a
transferable utility
game package in mathematica
uh i have no time to explore that and
see what's going on this picture is just
copy pasted here
okay literature games just rated games
okay so this is the final thing uh so if
you have a
a game you can say that this is
iterated and then you can ask that
how given behavior strategies which are
basically
functions which gives some kind of
output based on the game history
would compete with each other right
here this is a
kind of a simplified reproduction
reproduction of the
of the axa road tournament
results right how did for that and
random and the defector and the
cooperator would
play with each other and then uh
replicator dynamics used to
to see how the how the proportion of
these
strategies change as a function of time
so okay
okay let's zoom out for a second this is
very very nice
well done you've managed to uh
you know we've been flapping around
meaning to do something like this for
years
this looks like we're finally going to
get it get it nailed
fantastic okay let me ask some meta
questions
okay since i don't know this field at
all
you know in what you've shown what
fraction
if i looked at a big game theory
textbook and i looked at all the
different sections and so on what
fraction of those do you think you've
covered with things you've talked about
today
so i think instead
so there are many books uh this whole
uh thing is is based on an online course
uh on coursera
um this covers the
the course one and there is an advanced
course
uh and there are some other mechanism
designs and things like that
this is not included here so basically
it includes
most of the things what's happening in a
standard
game theory textbook and
the the evolutionary game theory part is
an extra
and the iterated games is a kind of
ex so it's it's sometimes they are
sometimes not
okay but so
from a design point of view okay next
question
you know it would be nice i think you
have managed to get this to the point
where i can imagine this being built in
system functionality
finally i mean we've been flapping
around with this for a long time so
i mean now the question is if we do that
how many how many symbols are we talking
about here
i mean i think that the the the budget
is probably
maybe four or five okay
it's not 15 or 20 or something it's
maybe four or five unless
um and then you know lots of detailed
things
are then accessed with properties and so
on
yeah so i think the the game solve is a
big
function uh it can take many options
and it can handle many different uh
objects like bayesian games games etc
uh here if you if you want we can talk
about beijing games sometimes as well
uh now we didn't had okay it's included
uh and and game solve can give
results for that as well so i think game
solve is a
is a big central function in this
then i think uh this
replicator dynamics is also something
big and and i think useful
to have why isn't it just a
possible output of game solve as the
differential equation
or no no not of game solve of game
object i mean if game object
is the fundamental thing then
why isn't replicated dynamics just a
property of that that produces a
differential equation well you also need
to give initial conditions you also need
to give a time
frame uh it could also have
its own separate uh options
because yeah there's all kinds of
population interaction dynamics too like
when you go to space
facial games then you've got populations
which can interact only with
subpopulations locally and and
all the replicator dynamics and winder
depending on things other than the game
itself and its solutions that are
related to the way the populations
interact
yes also here you you uh
you you could see that uh for example
the rock paper scissors games are
oscillate
is oscillating there are replicator
dynamics which
which try to shrink those things so
okay fine all right so there's the third
function what is that function what does
it
what does it i mean
what what does it take as input it takes
a game object and it takes certain
options that represent what is the input
and what's the output is the output
interpolating functions or is the output
you mean for replicator dynamics yes yes
yes the output is a
is a nested set of interpolating
functions okay
okay all right we're up to three
functions what else
i mean i see you've got others like game
iterate and so on here
uh yes
um well um
i i think this this this game tree
representation and and uh and
uh i think that that would be
uh that would be important as well
but but wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute the question is
from a design point of view is that its
own separate wrapper
which is very expensive or is it
something where from a game object
you can generate a graph
a tree whatever and you can feed a tree
or graph in
to produce a game object am i making
sense
well the thing is that in these two
representations
in the matrix representation and uh and
uh
and the tree representation um
i'm not hundred percent sure but i think
that there is a different set of
information
in the in the strategic form uh in the
tree representation
you also encode the game uh play
the the the sequential information
yeah in in the in the matrix
representation
um basically you that's how you would
told another person how to play instead
of you
that for every given you say what
it should be but in your argument that
game object should be an opaque
thing you don't need to worry about
these things you can just have accessors
that pull out whatever information you
need from each of these
each of these underlying representations
and in some cases
the you know it's not available yes but
i am not sure that the true
representation and
the matrix representation is totally
equivalent
it doesn't matter does it i mean in
other words
game object has some representation
inside it
certain properties are missing not
available
for you know if if you have the wrong
representation so to speak
i mean that would be the obvious design
way to do it so that that way
it doesn't matter that is somebody has
given you a game in this form or in that
form
and you can still use game solve you can
use the replicated dynamics things etc
the thing is that for example some
refinements of the of the nash
equilibrium as
there is for example refinement that
which is a
subgame uh perfect uh solution which
means that
uh if you have if you have a game tree
then
uh then in every sub branch
that equilibrium should be an
equilibrium
and that's i i don't see that how this
could
i mean for that you need to know that
that game is represented by a tree but
yeah right
great fine but so in that case if you
ask for that thing and you've got a game
represented by a matrix it says sorry i
can't tell you that
okay i don't think there's any problem
with that i think that the
important thing is that by having a
single uniform representation it's just
like
you know okay quiz you know in an
interpolating function
how many different internal
representations are there for an
interpolating function
i don't know you know there's a bunch of
different forms it can have
but it doesn't matter because all you
all you care about is that you can
evaluate it
at a particular point and it does a good
job of telling you the answer
and if you ask it there's a
representation of an interpolating
function
where you can go outside the domain
there's another one where you can't
and if if you try and go outside the
domain you use the wrong representations
to say sorry i don't have that value
okay and that's i mean it's a very
convenient way to package it
we are we are deeply running out of time
here but this was really good
and um uh i guess we should
uh schedule another one of these to go
through more details but i think
um you know i i think perhaps
you know we gave a few pointers for you
know
how to tighten up this design who um
uh should i notice one comment on our
live stream that i just want to
handle from muhammad here which is about
something quite different but i think
i'd like to know what it's about
um it had to do with uh categorical
distributions and i'm not sure we have
anybody here who's the right person to
to handle this question um
didn't implement categorical
distribution with conditionals
oh well can can somebody send this along
to the
publishing statistics team please
that's not for anybody here um
i'm sorry
okay roger you are almost unhearable
oh sorry about that should go to
ethiopia okay
fine sushma can do that i didn't know
you were here roger do you have any
comments on this whole
i think it looks pretty good i mean it's
it's it needs a lot of polish and
iteration but it
it looks promising in my mind
right do you have any comments on the
overall design directions here
of like the how many functions question
and so on
um i think that there's a lot more to
game theory than this but this is a good
start
yeah but the problem is we need to not
lock ourselves out of something
by having too simple a form for this
i think is this is the right place to
start i without
having gone deeper into it i can't have
a super informed
okay opinion i just know a lot of other
views
that's gonna come eventually from
various places
like what like the mechanism design i
think is important
i think differential games are super
important
um in control for instance
um but so for example hooking this into
our machine learning stuff
is one important piece um
and you know there's a need to
understand how those designs mesh
hooking it into the control theory stuff
how would that work
that that is what control design is it
solves games
i i understand that roger but we have a
control theory framework
and it has functions that accept
different kinds of things and if
you feed it you know a game object it's
going to be poisonous and the animal is
going to die
oh yeah no it doesn't deal with the same
things right but that's what i'm asking
is as i'm asking what do you need
because the thing i don't know i mean i
don't need anything from this this is
matrix games i don't think it's
okay but so can the control theory stuff
just like i'm saying
what we would like it to be the case is
that
you know a machine learning some you
know some random neural net
should be able to be put in as the
you know learning thing for game
learning here
that's what i'm suggesting and so that
it's easy to do that so now i'm asking
in your mechanism design thing if i
don't know you know a pid controller or
something is it
i have no idea whether that's no no no
mechanism design is much closer to this
this is like how do you how do you
incentivize people to use your new data
center
how do you incentivize people to be
truthful on their dating app
okay but but but but i'm asking the
question when
you know in our control theory you know
framework we have a whole bunch of
functions yeah how would those plug into
what you have here
i have no idea i don't they don't i mean
okay but but you're saying mechanism
design is something that comes from
control theory no mechanism design
it's a stupid name because of course
that mechanism all over the world
but that academic discipline that that
deals with mechanism design
what they design are kind of like
contracts in a way that incentivize you
to do
the right thing i'm running this this is
a version this is the wrong version
anyway never mind
okay this is not supposed to be this way
um
so i'm just trying to understand in in
this in this whole setup
is anything here something which should
interact with this game theory stuff
no okay
so there's no relationship between
control systems i i find that hard to
believe i mean i thought in economics
for example
that there were sort of common
okay well no i don't think that you
should try to get them to
interact at this point okay okay okay
fine
fine all right i just have one other
comment here so
on on the iterative game stuff there's a
lot of complications that come in with
uh population dynamics and spatial
versions et cetera
what what what's here is very nice for
the simplest case of that and like what
you saw in actual rod
it gets that uh correct um but um
as you want to generalize this and want
to apply it to uh the kinds of things
people do in in iterative game theory
um they're gonna want more control over
some of the things which here are like
hardwired as the simplest decisions
so um this is still a good start on all
that but the
specifically the iterative game things
here iterative games things here is
going to want more
ramification later it's going to want to
have more ability to control
what populations you have how they
interact and and
and uh those non-game aspects so to
speak
my my assumption is that there is a game
nest list effectively
which says you know in every round
take what i had before and figure out
how to
get what comes for the next round is
that a fair way to think about it
yes and there's different uh sort of
formulaic ways that are commonly looked
at for how to do that based upon
previous payoffs
um right but the the point is that um
who who actually played the game with
whom out of the previous population set
is handled in different ways in in these
in some of these setups some it's
everybody has an equal probability of of
playing everyone else someone is
everyone actually plays everyone else
with you know fi with finite weights on
them
yeah et cetera so um
those aspects wind up being the the
extra level of variables above the
um the one-shot game itself that are
parts of the iteration
all right so basically this is the way
to think about this is there's a kernel
that is like in nest list you know the
function that you're applying
and then there are things like uh well
fold pair lists and other complicated um
functional programming things where they
are basically controlling
what gets fed into each level of the
iteration
does that make sense yes and and some of
these methods of just having a simple
uh ode to solve to find the population
dynamics are not going to work in that
case you're going to have to do
something more discretized and and so on
go ahead this is something like a mean
field
approximation of of
realistic dynamics for example so there
is no special spatial information for
example
right there's no connectedness
information et cetera
right right so so what jason is saying
is
in general the state that is iterated
upon by the game kernel
could be some more complicated state
that could for example have spatial
information or graph
you know a graph or something like this
and in addition
the the way that the game kernel acts on
that i mean
it's reminiscent of things like for
example we have functions like block map
that will take you know an array and
decide it's going to pick out these
you know these you know three by two
blocks or something
to apply a function to and then the
function eats
you know i i think it just eats the the
flattened
list of things but
the block map function is responsible
for
deciding what piece of the of the you
know state
to pull out to to feed into the kernel
does that kind of right that that makes
sense i mean i think what we're going to
want here is something like a you know
game population evolve or something
and and uh that's it's generic like that
and where this this would be a special
case
um within it um and then
all of the other stuff underneath here
for the uh how you use
nd solve to get the dynamics would then
work um in that case
right sounds sounds more or less right
to me i mean i think the thing
thing we're talking about there is sort
of functional programming where
there are you know different ways to
collect
arguments to feed to the colonel and
then what you're saying i think joseph
is that you know there are particular
ways to set up those colons
and those ways you know like the mean
field case where essentially you're just
taking probably in effect the mean of a
bunch of values
yes um and uh you know and then feeding
in a single value into the kernel the
colonel expects only one value and it's
going to generate one or
some major values um and uh
but okay but so i think there's a
probably a nice design that can be made
that sort of allows for the general case
even though maybe at the beginning we
don't implement the general case we just
implement
some named cases that correspond to
particular
you know common things and we have
deeply run out of time and i am supposed
to go
work on chemistry here um so
uh that was really good and um
you know to be continued and thanks to
everybody who is here
i see we have oh gosh we have several
visitors here whose opinions i would
love to get but but
um we really ran out of time so i think
um
perhaps those can be gotten offline um
all right well thanks a lot guys thanks
to folks on the live stream
we are about to do another live stream
about chemistry for those who are
interested in that
okay see you all soon
okay for people joining this live stream
busy day today we were just doing game
theory now we're doing chemistry
so um
okay that's cool okay improvements to
molecule
draw okay oh we have plot themes for
molecule plot 3d
don't get your hopes up before you reach
the end of that sentence it was more of
a uh
12.3 sorry i should lead with that
yeah okay okay new functions molecule
name what is that
is that why is that not just common name
let's see uh because common name to my
knowledge is
exclusively goes to the knowledge base
no no no no but that's just that's just
what we've chosen it to do
they did yeah i had the same uh question
because there isn't one there isn't a
unique one there are many
it's not a common name and there are
many possibilities
i see so if i if i were to type in some
random thing here
you would need to wrap that in molecule
the uh string
okay that should be unnecessary okay
i'll make a note of that
wow okay do we believe it
so this is one of the uh the functions
that i use all the time that's currently
in the the function repository um
we've had a fair amount of what is that
what is that what is that what is that
what is that what
why am i seeing some weird thing about
querying cactuses
so i can i can uh so that's one of the
questions here is
we're querying a few different external
services when you make that
uh call and so i
whether we need to say that we're
calling that service or not okay i don't
think it's relevant to people unless it
fails
i mean unless it's going to take a long
time well so it can take a long time
which is why i thought it needed
something
so then in that case in that case we
give a progress monitor
but but that progress monitor with the
black there isn't it doesn't follow the
progress monitor
guidelines did you did you make that as
a custom thing
no so i'm using evaluate with progress
but uh i'm new to it so i
okay it doesn't look like it's the right
quite the right form
for that but now if i put in a what can
i put in here
help help me out with a with a random
chemical thing
something weird here if i put a sulfur
on the end is it going to do anything i
mean is it going to
okay it's very easy to find a molecule
that uh that nobody has put into any
database
okay fine fine but isn't isn't there a i
mean doesn't iupac just define
a um a way of naming things
that will work for pretty much any
molecule right but there's no
there's no algor there's no software out
there that will uh
that will generate them or if there is
there are there are some software that
will generate
molecule names but it but
this is [ __ ] i mean come on there's
an algorithm right
iupac defines an algorithm for doing
this it's not even a terribly
complicated algorithm
but it's interesting
that's the problem so the problem is
there is a standard for naming molecules
but which somebody made up and and some
set of people were sitting in some room
one day
and they said well what should we do in
this case oh let's add this paragraph to
represent that case
and then poor software people have to go
implement what that paragraph says is
that basically the point
correct yes
and and people have done that
painstakingly perhaps
and um and does anybody care
i believe it's just definitely needed in
the pharmaceutical industry for filing
patents
okay
and the name is the name generated in
that way is an
unambiguous representation of the
molecule
or intended to be okay so
it's a separate project to go and just
implement
or to somehow license some
implementation
of the you know given the smile
string or whatever what is the name
right that's a that's a separate
factored project
but what's being done here is to cover a
large fraction of useful cases is that
correct
yes okay so
okay so presumably there should be some
method i mean presumably we could do
something where there's a
service connection that uses service
credits to go
query some you know pay database
for the more complicated cases is that a
true statement
if we cared yeah yes if such a database
were
available and had an api with with um um
okay we'll find that that's a separate
um separate thing
i think i think there might be somebody
in the company who might know how to
get access to that we'll talk about that
separately yeah
it wouldn't be a database either would
have to be an algorithm for you know for
as a service right i understand
okay but but so
uh i mean let's let's separately we can
talk about
how that might be achieved but but right
now here
there are external apis that you are
querying
correct for in certain cases is that is
that a true statement
correct it was what i saw with the
cactus saying right so
first we checked the knowledge base and
if and then we go to pubchem and then
cactus okay
okay and so
um
right
we are saying you should have something
that we can say which service we are
using
with only one public import look look
look look
there should be a method option to
molecule name which says something about
yeah you should have a method option
here
okay okay that allows you to specify
those things and possibly even the order
in which they're tried
now in terms of what the progress
monitor says you know
the the standard way to deal with the
evaluate with progress so to speak
is you know if it if it comes back in a
few seconds don't bother to say anything
about it
right right i set the delay to one
right now but uh i would have it longer
than that i think the the likelihood is
it's going to just work
and if it doesn't just work it's because
you're not connected to the internet or
something that's going to fail forever
am i making sense i don't know i don't
know how many i
i think it's
um and then what you should do and i'm
not the expert on on how we're setting
these up
but um um
you should make it clear i mean when
somebody sees something about cactuses
here
they're like completely confused right
there
you know you know what cactus is but
other people do not
so um i think you should say
something like um
querying external cactus service or
something
did you understand what i'm saying
yes and so i mean so should it be just
querying external services or
no i think you should say which service
it is because could be that one of them
is down or
you know something like this right
you know querying external cactus
service dot dot dot
querying external um
or maybe just querying external service
param cactus or something
querying external service um
uh
yeah okay
all right but so there's some business
development stuff to do around which we
can
talk about separately to do with with
figuring out whether we can get
access to more sophisticated algorithms
here
um
okay so so in this
okay so that seems kind of lame i mean
what happens
so there might be three different uh you
know does pubchem could pubchem have
three different molecule names in it
for a single molecule yeah no pubchem
can have
uh several yeah okay so what are we
going to do in that case
so we had differences of opinion in the
group others
and said that we should be able to
return the list and also an association
with service goes to and then list
i myself want generally a
simple function i want a function that
is just going to give me well i think
we can get both of what we want i mean
the so i would have a second argument i
would say
the first case is just give me a name
right and the second case would be
you have a second argument here which
would say something like
um uh
let's see i mean we would say i don't
know
i'm making this up and this isn't a very
good thing but something like all names
or something
names list
see what i'm saying and then and then
that would give you a list of all the
known
well um
i don't know whether that's the right
thing or whether what you want to get
out
is something which says you know pubchem
reports
these things a list of names here
so and so reports this thing that's what
the association was going to give
yeah that's very in keeping with what uh
jan and
bob were suggesting
what i would prefer if i was using it
well why don't we just have a second
argument
give you that and the default when there
isn't a second argument is what jason
wants
and just give a single name yeah
so and then so the so the second
argument could be the
so i would think to make the second
argument the string name of the service
or the symbol all but uh that's fine
that's sensible
the only problem is if you tell me that
pubchem can have seven results oh i see
what you're saying
it just returns a
okay so so then the default
okay so the default would be automatic
which means give me one
then what what would happen is if you
say pubchem here
then it would give you the list of
pubchem results is that correct
right which could possibly be empty yeah
right and then all would give you the
association of all of them
yes seems sensible to me
now this string here
um presumably there's a service
connection
that can that is doing this pubchem
thing is that correct
right pubchem is through a service
connect and chem spider is
one of the the external services i call
has a
an api that's far too simple for service
connect and so i just
make the call myself
um
okay i mean it might be nice to pack it
package it
you know in a service connect it's a
cheap service connect presumably
right i've reached out to them to the um
christian's team and
so they were their question was uh what
would should
do we need to to do that uh well
probably the answer is no but i mean it
might be
it might be nice to do it and they are
supposed to have a lightweight framework
which may not be ready yet
once they have their lightweight
framework i would suggest doing it
okay if it changes then we do you just
update the service connect right you
don't have to update the code then
it should be going through well and also
the other point is
that if there's a standardized way that
the service connect is called
you could add another service here and
have it just work
by adding something to the service
connections
right good
okay on we go fine this looks nice find
molecular identifiers
right and so for 12.1 when uh
molecule instead of molecular um
for 12.1 uh when external identifiers
were introduced
i put these as properties for the
molecule
but tony pointed out and i ended up
agreeing with him that
you should that to have a molecule
property
make an internet call without it when it
wasn't clear to the user that doing
it was going to do so um that it's not
the best practice and also there would
be a case where some of these
services would hang and you would be
calling for all the properties on a
molecule and
wonder why is it taking so long and so
it's just more clear if it's a single
it's a well so wait a minute so you're
removing it from the molecule properties
let's see so they were de-documented you
can still ask for the property and it
will still work
but it's not on the the documentation
page and so it's going to this is the
would be the documented way to get the
external identifiers
what's our standard way of getting
external identifier for for another
entity value is the only way that i know
but
i see but so if i want to get the wiki
you know if i have a person and i want
to get the
the wiki data id how do i do that
you know what i'm asking how do i get
that yes and i mean i believe
linguistics are hooked up for the
for that uh so if i say something like
alan turing wiki data
identifier that should hopefully work
it's not looking like it's working oh
what's that
that's weird drop this how do i get some
i think flipping big data data around it
wasn't that sorry we need the second
argument
specified property but by the way this
should error out if it's not going to
work
this should explain it has too few
arguments it shouldn't just fail
yep
um
what on earth should it be
no there's a left page example that does
work so
right now so wiki data id right was the
name of the property
okay i'm now completely confused but
then the single the one argument form
what's it supposed to do
michael what's the one argument form
supposed to do no right now we don't
have a documented one argument form
okay well so fine so let's make it error
out yeah
okay but so this is a way of getting
that external identifier this thing here
is an external identifier but it's very
special
it's not the general i mean we have we
have a hundred or something that just
works for wiki to get this identifier
right i contacted tony about whether we
would ever want
a like general uh find external
identifier function and
we agreed that it would be useful but
hard to implement
generally um in that it wouldn't be
quite clear what the argument of this
function would be
right so for every partic it's not clear
i mean
what object types would have
corresponding uh
um identifiers besides entities
it wasn't it wasn't clear but so so he
suggested i might be better off just
making
one specifically for molecules
and wait a minute
lists of external identifier objects
hmm
so some identifiers are supposed to be
unique so there should only be one
compound id but some are definitely not
so there would be multiple substance ids
and so the default is just to always use
a list
[Music]
i mean okay so the basic issue is
you've got a thing represented
symbolically in our language and there
is an external
database wiki data pubchem whatever
that also supposedly has a thing that
represents the same
you know objectives in some way
yes yes that's correct okay
and so why is it that we don't want to
have a general version of this
because the sink we can
rarely represent other than an entity
molecule is an exception
we don't have we don't have say
or more to the point they're right not x
the polynomial x squared minus 1
doesn't have any particularly useful
external identification
yes exactly
right so the point is that the
mean like i mean there are external
identifiers like we could say
given this geo position what is its you
know what three words designation or
something
i think we have that that particular
hmm well but
but say it's it's it's like single the
big ones it's dui is
200 million and other than say just a
string or something like this we
wouldn't have a representation of it
well not yet we're planning hopefully
we're going to get back to that
bibliography stuff
before too long but then wouldn't it not
be the
identifier itself like like
on the doi other than going to the
database we can infer no information but
for molecules
we can infer non-information without
the outside world because
we have a representation of it yeah okay
fair enough
um all right so let's see
find molecule identifiers
i'm i'm troubled by the s at the end
but i mean what's the default if you
just give one argument
is there a default it returns an
association with uh
all so if you scroll down there's an
example i believe
um find all available for
at the bottom
you might have picked a simpler molecule
than there might have been fewer
it was it was uh tricky i first chose
water and there are a lot of substance
records deposited for
water really let's try it what happens
if i say something like
um just for fun
that should be present there
what what is finding chem what does that
mean so those are the
the specific exercises
so so this happened to bob earlier and
so uh
so essentially we are using a service
connection and we this has been
this is in the system um
you are in order to use that you would
need to go and create a
chems spider api key
it's true i mean so i could disable it
because this is
uh not pleasant but i added
several years ago and it's just worked
ever since i understand but that's not
good enough i mean
why don't we go make a deal with
chemspider so we don't have to do this
right we've interacted with those guys
for years
surely we can figure out a way to avoid
this because this is going to kill off
anybody who wants to use this
okay this is a non-starter it's not
going to work so i can remove chem
spider
from the default no i we should go make
a deal so that you don't have to do this
right that's the right answer i've made
a note of it
okay okay but i wish you'd kind of like
told me before i tried this
something like this was going to happen
because this is a completely
not something that can happen with our
you know
the only thing we can do which we do do
with some functions that use
um external services is to put up some
kind of
terms of service screen
right and that would be
probably the deal we would make here my
american sense
yes so i mean i'll talk to christian and
alan
about yeah they're not quite the right
people but they can start there
okay okay
okay so
uh and again those that you know i don't
know why that isn't in the
the progress monitoring guidelines but i
mean it should end
dot dot dot and things like that and it
should you know
it's not the right progress monitor uh
message um should i
check with um giulio is he he's the one
who's designed i think so
i don't know somebody else might know
who's is there anybody here who's
project managing
yes okay
well do you want the molecule record
this is necessary do you also want a
script here
i'm sorry what that doesn't what do you
want molecule required here and
fight molecule identifies it not really
anymore right no
you don't obviously you don't need to
have molecule there
obviously it should just work with this
i don't know whether it will
no so that's wrong right it will fix it
yes
okay it's a little weird
but useful for people i understand
i understand that
fine okay
i bothers me it bothers me to not have
this be part of the properties
i mean the fact that there's some random
external service involved
is just like a detail it shouldn't be
part of the story of what the
functionality is
so the thing that bothered me was when i
would ask for all the properties of a
molecule and it would
and they should be computable and they
should be very fast and then you've got
that just this one that
inexplicably takes well right but that's
just a stupid implementation problem
not something that we give you know that
we feed to users
right that's not a reason to do this
right there's a reason that's a reason
to think about the design
of all in the case of properties of a
molecule how do you ask for all
properties of a molecule
do you understand my question i do i do
um
i'm trying to remember right so you
don't even know so it so this
case is okay so for example if i say
here
data set for example okay
okay 107 values all right that's not the
molecule that's an entity
okay well so what is the corresponding
thing for a molecule
that's a good question okay so then what
is the thing that you're complaining
doesn't work
let's see so the exact syntax uh whether
let's see so give me okay so look
here's what i think you should do okay i
i don't think it's a good idea to i mean
it may be convenient if this is an
incredibly common operation to try and
find these identifiers
then have a function for it but if this
is some kind of hack
to deal with the fact that it might be
slow to query some external api
because we happen to be using an
external api this week
is you know that's the wrong thing and
instead what we should do
is you know whatever the default give me
all properties which
you don't even seem to know what it is
that you know just should
not include this property and then you
should be able to ask for this property
using the same mechanism
but as a convenience if you're giving
the whole sort of card
about the molecule either we cache the
result
or we um right which also would not be
an unreasonable thing to do
for many molecules or we um
uh you know or we don't include that on
the list of things you get by default
just like
there'll be other things that we don't
include by default because they haven't
been measured for that molecule
or whatever else so okay so
so the fact is i i push this as
that as the reason but to be honest i i
do think that this
is a good function and it is good but
can you answer the question how do i get
all the properties of a molecule
well so i haven't tabbed over so so if
you do molecule value
of all properties you get a list of all
the properties available okay so that's
a complete so so this
this case that you described is not a
real case
of of um of of it oh it's slow
that's just not a real case so we can
take that off the table
right i mean you know there may be some
case where we have to not include
these external identifiers in our
generic list of properties of a molecule
which would be fine right so the fact is
i like molecule value as doing computed
properties and i like the fact that this
is molecule identifiers it's always
going to go out and
it clearly separates this is something
it's not a computed property it's
something that we are getting from
outside so molecule identifiers isn't
going to give you the smile string
because we compute that
it doesn't give you the answer no no no
no
no look the fact is no
i mean this distinction is is something
which you understand very well because
you're
you know this is what you're doing and
you're living it but the question of
whether the smile string come
i wouldn't know whether this mastering i
i think i know that it's just computed
but i don't know whether there's some
canonicalizer for smile strings
that involve some external service i
have no idea
and i don't care right i mean in other
words
that this distinction between things
that we compute internally and things
for which we go
to an external service if there is a
canonical if
if the thing for the external services
the accession number of this molecule
this
cas accession number or something to
this molecule then i understand that's
something you're going to go to an
external service for that's a different
kind of thing
but if it's something which
fundamentally it's an algorithm but we
didn't happen to
implement that algorithm so we're going
to an external service for it that's
irrelevant to the user
so which is it in this case no it is not
the case here we
want an identifier which is not a
computer thing
neither we know somebody else can
compute it no i understand
so that's okay
by the way i don't think we should say
we should call this find molecule
identifiers because there's not a lot of
the fact that you know that it's going
to something i mean we don't say
find because we have to you know like
like um
you know we say genome lookup not find
genome lookup just because it has to go
to a different computer type thing
are making sense yes
so do i mean okay so you're saying
molecule value
is a property of the molecule
but i think molecule identifiers should
also support the smile string and the
entry string
because the fact that those happen to be
computable identifiers
doesn't seem to me relevant
you see what i'm saying and externally
they're also referred to
as identifiers so the users are going to
expect that
you go to wiki on wikipedia on any
compound and
inching smiles will be there under the
identifiers
right so so i think that would that will
be fine i mean so
molecule identifiers would then return
all identifiers whether they come
whether they're sort of a named cast
registry number or whether they're
something like smiles does that jason
does that make sense to you
no not i mean so let's see so so either
we just take all of these and make them
into molecule properties so this is a
function right now that only that
returns always
external identifiers i don't know oh i
see external identifier objects
so if i mean so we can just scrap this
function and fold those all back
into being no no no no i'm not
suggesting that i'm selecting something
different okay
molecule value it happily computes
computed properties which includes the
smile string
which is a computed thing right makes
sense
now the point that i'm making here is
the notion of a molecule identifier
is should include thing okay so the
issue is
these things are external identifier
objects not strings
identifiers used in two different
meanings
um
i see where steven's coming from because
anything that's not the chemical name or
the chemical formula is a molecular
identifier
strictly speaking yeah
but this identifier in the function name
refers to the
external ones i know i know so unless we
said molecule external identifiers
okay which would clarify what that is
how about i i agree that that isn't
molecule value i agree that the external
identifiers
are probably not something that because
entity value does entity value give the
wiki data identifier or not
we do have a property i'm not sure right
now if it's exposed
but but we have it immediately handy we
don't have to go somewhere to get it
right so entity value i mean it doesn't
have just computed properties it has
uh curated but but
only we look in our own think we know
how to do it quickly and
without complications
what if we name this uh molecule
identifier lookup
instead of fine molecular identifiers
that makes good sense i like that
yeah that makes good sense it is looking
up
external databases which the user
shouldn't
care about in theory but it is doing a
lookup
so i look up in the name looks sensible
to me
i agree with you but okay
listen we've clearly got a much more to
go through here we've got probably
another
hour and a half of stuff and i can't do
that right now so i think we should
probably wrap it up
for now and reschedule this for
later and i look forward these all look
very interesting
i'm sorry to make the one that was
supposed to be trivial not so trivial
um uh is there anything just
just one last thing for one minute
anything cool to see here
just for fun let's see i mean so maximum
common substructure has gotten a
bit of a revamp and so now i understand
i'm just asking if there's some
interesting thing to just see
there's just a cool thing that um
molecular line
yeah the uh estradiol and
uh reservitol example
what does a line mean in the case of a i
mean well i'm about to find out
indeed further further down
that uh not that one uh
here we are this one
people are suggesting we have more
tungstens in here i don't know how much
we can do on tungsten can
say uh okay
so what does this mean so this this is
this is which pieces of the molecule
so i mean is this sort of preparing okay
the way it works the way it works you
you give it
a molecule as a reference and one or
more molecules will get aligned to it
you have to specify which atoms are
important for the
geometric comparison that's the third
argument
and then it will align the molecules in
the second argument
to the one in the first argument uh by
minimizing the
uh distance
deviation between uh after doing a rigid
translation
and rotation yeah this is definitely
cool
very nice yeah and this example um
the uh reserve resveratol
is an estrogen it's a hormone disruptor
and it matches very closely to the
estradiol
structure very nice okay this is
interesting all right i look forward to
this
we'll do it another time um so
thanks guys and um